Hello everyone bet you didn't expect me to come from there welcome to another video
What's that t-series have been in the lead for the past couple of days?
*LWIAY Intro*(noam)
Who cares about sub count anyway honestly so lame this is all just a troll it was a big troll
I said it I don't care about numbers. I don't care. I really don't care
*9 year old swede spazzing out* I don't care! I don't fckin care
*spit flies everywhere due to tantrum*
Should we just jump into it skedaddle article 13. Oh god of great. Can Kim something good come out of this life, huh?
HiT oR mIsS i BeT yOu NeVeR mIsS
What goddamn they just did that guess why I'm in Japan I
Think that the annoying part, is that no one knows
What's gonna happen if it was clear the rules going like okay now you can't do this or okay
Blah blah blah it would be okay, but now there's so much doubt and confusion
So I would wait a little bit before we go full-on *burps* panic
But I am 100% moving country it's a subtle move. I could have posted this
Alright, I saw this mean long ago very long ago. That's why I didn't skratta when I saw this meme. Hi Felix
I'm 9 years old
*9 year old Swedish meatball* Damn
the perfect age
Sounds weird for me to say from Norway and I'm in the hospital
Your content mails me happy in the darkest of times, and I just wanted to say thank you
brofist
Hope you're doing well. Soon. Tat. One guy all the best the 9 year olds are rooting for you
I said we're no nine year old dare to stand in merch!
Absolute power move. Well done. Random Indian guy. Well, first of all because of the hue tube algorithm
Guys don't tell him but the 90 million Club merch is out now and it's looking hella sicka dicka get look at it
It's very nice. Look very cool
Wikipedia changing the most subscribe YouTube channel for the hundred and twenty second time this week
heh heh, well, you know it's gonna be the last when we take over
Felix should do a 12-hour
Stream at ninety nine million so we can witness the sub count passing 100 mill
That is a great idea. But let's get real here T-Series has already passed. (Sadly) Let's just acknowledge the situation
It's over
Okay, you've might as well buy the 90 million Club merch now because we ain't never gonna get to a hundred. This is sad
I'm crying and shaking Ben Shapiro destroys marvel. What if Avengers endgame?
It's just three hours of famous teaching us agriculture
it ain't much but it's all a surviv- *starts giggling like a little swede boy* the weird part about this is I don't actually know if
This is real or fake
Holy crap. I found Markiplier
*laughing and wheezing*
Know where this is from where is this from? It does look strikingly like him. Very nice
Chin Goals, is that a subreddit?
shame
What a damn shame
Someone needs some create chin goals right freaking now one subscriber set up 91 million set up
I recorded that on my iPhone, I remember. Okay, stop making fun of my setup. Alright, the quality is the best. Okay
Yeah, everyone's saying that the quality is better here in Japan. Oh, there we go. Look at that Felix camera quality
Felix camera quality in Japan
*anime girl imitation*aaahh wow
I think you guys are probably right. I probably use the wrong settings.
I need to change it when I started OBS here
It said like hey, do you want to use the best setting for streaming or recording? I'm like well
recording
me when I don't skip a pip I add because that money is my wedding gift to
Felix and Marcia it mugs, but it's honest work
Thank you so much found an old photo with me with Felix and Marcia. What's great to meet you?
See, this is what people don't realize that's how I look like
That's my appearance
JK Rowling is big gay being gay isn't a choice
It's an involuntary thing that happens when JK Rowling decides, it's your time
JK Rowling's the ruler of gays Hey look you found me again
Jesus Christ huge sighting today in Tokyo as I am
188 I can confirm he's at least 180 the best height of all time
I'm not insecure about my height though. I didn't see his Footwear
Keep it that way
Far away respect his holiday since then. I took a picture of him
Makes no sense
Sorry have a nice trip in Japan. I like this photo cuz it looks like might say is completely dead inside
I'm like showing my phone to her me like hey might see a look at this meme and she's just like oh god
No
please not another one my shit looks like she's having
Vietnam flashbacks as a fellow Italian I can confirm that's the face we make when we see overcooked
F's in the chance for mine to everyone to the range
This is the Marvel movie. I want to see if dr. Phil is not in the Marvel Cinematic
Endgame a speeding beating up vanish. I don't know how they're possibly gonna defeat him
Then one mean to rule them all he always joked that there's one mean that's just gonna surpass them all one superior mean
That's gonna transcend the human race. Could it be could it be Ricardo Morelos?
Only time will tell but so far my god. He's defeated Death himself and me review
Doing my part in Christian Sun No in the log of the region Bros
The earth should not be hotter than Shrek. Yeah, I agree. Well done Norway surprised me
I am blue shirt kid. Like I play a lot of fortnight. You are the color
Thank You blue shirt kid for hosting me review one of our finest meme review so far oh god no, oh god
Oh god. No, I didn't think it would come to this
Don't look at this. This is fake memes. That's it these shoes
They look like they have a big plateau. But really my feet are touching the ground
It's just an illusion like an optical illusion. The soul is actually this big on the inside. So, thank you
Yes 180
confirmed alright glide glide we got that out of the way EU faves means in Europe, you know, I'm something of a Japanese
Myself, I mean it came at a good time. You did it. I guess I just have to stay here
It's either that or quit so I don't know man t-series. We're the most subscribed channel PewDiePie, man
This war has been going on for like six months now. I can't believe it's still happening. Oh god, no
Oh god. Oh god. It hurts. I can't look at it. It's first to 100 million P series
You ain't won nothing yet
That's right I spit on you he was making his feel at home with his usual
Quality while he is in Japan. I'm so thoughtful you guys are why?
Can you imagine what my camera at home feels like I used the exact same camera because I brought it here then
How is the quality better in Japan? This makes zero sense?
You can't make it to the Y on a calculator me sit
How do you even make this that's really though well done normal wasabi
What women think men want what men really want? I cannot read this meme and pretend that I'm okay with it
Okay
There are also women watching this channel that are also very much wanting to get the hundred million now
I can't speak for all women, but this is exactly what they want. And this is what they only want 100 million
Alright Marvel infinity war it's the most ambitious
crossover event in history
Me. Oh
God, this meme never dies does it but there's two blue shirt kids
Nani
Appears telling me there will be a brofist that a hundred million me at a hundred million. It's not even gonna compare
Okay, it's gonna be the ultimate one punch experience of your life. You won't live through this bro fish. You don't understand
dude falou ready
sad
This is a really sad episode is it there it feels weird
Hey, this is the first love why I record where we're not technically winning sand
Just sad it smash like if you were also sad can we show this man some love? Oh, I actually saw this this morning
I posted on Twitter. It's amazing. It really suits. Today's episode doesn't he?
Feeling - it doesn't
Okay, thank you for watching another episode of the why keep the memes coming
That's the only thing keeping much alive at this moment
A hundred mil is coming check out the 90 million merch and I see you browse keys on the hosts keys
Brofist at a hundred million and that evolution of dance video
I got the here is blue
What super simulators becoming relevant
No, no, don't leave
No, please sponsor Eagle. Please do something
Yes
This game is still relevant god dammit